i'm not gonna do any work i'm just gonna
continue to be natural
and we'll see maybe i'll be an example
of what actually aging healthily looks
like he's an example of such
health to never have needed antibiotics
in nine years
and to never have needed any kind of
medical intervention because he's
healthy you know sister of the groom
such a fun movie for me to watch i'm
curious though for you as an actress
what is it that draws you to a project
like this
well the role i think this character
she's so
she's unraveling you know she's so
anxious and uncomfortable in her body
from these twins that she has
this happens to some people where their
bellies get that sort of
stretched thing that doesn't go back
she's really self-conscious about it and
wants to get enough
surgery and she's really vain and
in just struggling inside not
comfortable won't sleep with her husband
right now
all kinds of problems they're going to
see her
her brother who she's so close with and
he's marrying this younger woman that
he's never she's never
met before and she gets there and it's
just one assault after the other
you know it's like and
and she's already a mess making out with
her old boyfriend what is she doing he's
uncomfortable with you coming to the
wedding anymore you just have
toxic energy just wanted to get close to
you what's happening
just a little molly you're gonna be fine
you touched on this whole
theme of of body image you know i think
regardless of whether you've had a baby
or not especially a year like this you
look in the mirror you don't always
feel your best um is that something that
you can personally relate to
after i had my baby yes i mean it's like
if you get your period or
what i'm just talking to someone who
said it's my lunch
you know like sometimes if you just have
if you're in tight clothes and you eat
lunch
yeah you know your body gets it just
like gets
a little puffy and then it goes back
down like in the morning you're back to
normal
right right burrito or baby right yeah
exactly
it's just like everybody needs to calm
down don't ask a woman if she's pregnant
period how about that right i think
that's a good rule we can all live by
the idea of turning 40. it's something
that your character audrey is
you know i think she's kind of taken it
moment by moment
what for you was turning 40 something
you looked forward to or were you kind
of like
pump the brakes when you age what i what
i've noticed makes me feel better i
don't know if this makes anybody else
feel better is we all do it together
no one is exactly good like it's not
like you're the only one
so i need your friends you're all doing
it together for sure
for sure nobody is exempt from the aging
process and i think
like you've pointed out you know
throughout your career and your life
uh if you make smart decisions you can
kind of help yourself a little bit along
the
way
and i'm excited about being like i'm not
gonna do any work
i'm just gonna continue to be natural
and um
and we'll see maybe i'll be an example
of what actually aging healthily looks
like well i don't wanna do
any i would never i don't wanna put
anything in my body and like mess
i i want to naturally age i want to be
i don't know who else is doing that but
it seems like a small
tiny little person in our industry yeah
if there's anyone else out there
yeah if there is it would be a fun
little tiny
group to be in and see what that looks
like because i think that on film you
i would like to represent humans right
not people because most of the people
out there are not doing that
okay so for you everything is completely
off the table
not never going to happen i have no
intention of doing it i'll let you know
if it changes wouldn't it be nice
because if more of us didn't do it then
we wouldn't feel
odd aging together right or right it
normalizes
little lines and man it's beautiful for
sure and husband
always used to say how beautiful my
mommy was and she had
you know she was an older woman she had
wrinkles all over her face and
and he really admired her and i just
thought that's so lovely that he can
recognize
the beauty in a woman as she's aging
naturally and of course you know
ultimately the movie's about
true love you've got you know this
married couple they're trying to keep
the flame alive
you've got this bride and groom they're
trying to you know solidify
are we the right fit for each other um
for you is is there a flame is is dating
a possibility in quarantine
i have no boyfriend right now okay i
am looking for my you know
extraordinary unicorn and
when they show up you'll know
well but not yet you are an
extraordinary unicorn and i think
one of the reasons why people like
myself have always felt so connected to
you
is that you are a woman who you are you
have such clear vision
i have to imagine that someone with with
so much clarity
knows exactly what they want in a
partner are there things that are like
non-negotiables that you will look for
in your next partner
i think the main thing is wanting
someone that's really happy in their
skin
most of the time you know because
someone's solid my son is extraordinary
and so
it's got to be someone extraordinary to
bring to play with him
you know my heart is very open and i'm
super happy with whatever
whatever's meant to happen you mentioned
your son bear who really is
extraordinary and it's so exciting for
fans who follow you on instagram to
follow along
um with your parenting journey i'm just
curious if you anticipated
how big of a reaction uh his big haircut
was gonna get with with your fans
what are we doing right now cutting my
hair why
i have no idea oh my gosh oh
my gosh there he is that's even cute
here there's one there's one i am
always surprised by what people that
people pay attention to anything i'm sad
i remember posting things on the kind
life thinking this is just my
you know conscious healthy you know
aware people that are going to read this
not the world but then somehow somebody
picks it up and they go
and um so yeah i'm always surprised
but how is bear doing with his
with his new shorter due and how are you
is this an emotional process for you
when it happened yeah it was
we both we went home together and we got
in bed and we were like
both looking at each other like
something had happened
it was really it felt that big it was
like
a new person and um but he's he's
you know he's so great his hair's
growing back in and it's it's very cute
and his hair will be back to his waist
soon i'm sure but in no time
who knows the kid can grow a beautiful
head of hair that's for sure
i'm just curious what does bear make of
being such a standout on your social
media page does he get like post
approval before you put something up
what does he think about everything he
doesn't really know
i mean he does he knows he's on there
but he's not looking at that post and
you know address and seeing com he not
none of that he's i keep him far away
from
the reason i i put bear on social media
at
all is one because obviously i'm a very
proud mother
also because um you know it's it keeps
it keeps it less interesting for
paparazzi to harass us
uh when you take the power away took the
power away it happened when
when bear was born that um you know i
was able to
really people are camped outside the
house for days and days and the moment i
released an image they all went away
so i was like oh you know it works you
know and then the biggest
reason that i love sharing him with the
world is because he's such an example of
health
he's plant-based god forbid right and uh
he's an example of such
health you know to to never have needed
antibiotics in nine years
and to never have needed any kind of
medical intervention because he's
healthy you know most kids have so many
ear infections and so many
they're on so many they're taking
medicine all the time
and i'm not saying i wouldn't give it to
him if he didn't need it i'm saying he
doesn't need it so he can get a snot
nose but he's like still climbing trees
okay like he's just so healthy
i just would love to talk a little bit
about your incredible career
i think today you've got sister of the
groom but if we go down
almost three decades there's just so
many incredible
credits to your name is there one
project of yours
that really stands out as being
underrated
that's a good question um i feel like
the the main thing is i love doing
theater and
um it's so wonderful because you'll do a
play
that some people see and the people who
see it
it's such an incredible experience to
exchange with them and they know
so they've seen you do something that
was so intimate and
special and but then the rest of the
world doesn't get to see it and they
never know
and it's not on your imdb page when
someone who saw you in this thing
says hey i saw you in this play and you
know
how special that play was it's really
exciting i've been doing really i've
been just enjoying my work
and you know i'm an activist and i care
very much about people's health
in the world and i'm also really happy
that i found a way to also act because
for a long time i only did that stuff
because i was so focused on it and it's
hard to write a book
it takes a lot of time i know it's hard
to be an entrepreneur
um and to have your hand in so many
things i know you're a woman of the
theater is that
what you would say is next on your
bucket list you want to tap more into
that
as soon as the world opens up and you
can have your pick i would love to do
theater again
for sure and i will continue to
hopefully do theater until the day i die
i'm just having so much
fun working as an actress and i'm gonna
go shoot babysitter's club
the second season in um february and my
son's coming with me for the whole time
and um get a little a little cameo
appearance a little hats too to be
allowed to do it
isn't that weird like because of covid
the rules
he can't come unless he's in it so they
put him in it
is is he your son is he the youngest
child's best friend i think at least he
don't put pressure on him what if he
gets cut out
i all the point was is that he got to
come
but has it has it dawned on you that
you're gonna be working opposite your
son is that
just so exciting or emotional well he
was also and sister of the groom if you
look hard enough
there's a long-haired boy running around
in that wedding
but does he have the acting bug no not
at all
oh it's this thing yeah no he doesn't
want to be an actor he um i mean
he's nine he wants to do millions of
things right
last year he wanted to be a rapper
before that he was really intent on
being a navy seal
so you know it's changes and we'll see
where he lands
all i wanted was to be able to bring my
baby to work because you know we have to
support working mothers too
right and and i um i couldn't like
you know i can't i'm not gonna leave my
kid for a month
that's not happening out of the question
[Music]
you